i have an announcement let's not make
this awkward let's just jump right into
it after years
of being a poor poor detective in the 10
million dollar studio it's time
to sell out
to sell out
can we make this faster
um to sell out of to sell out of of
merch
sell out i have i i have merch
shopthething.com i don't know look
before you guys go all in and i know you
see these graphics you're sayings
where do i buy no wait wait a second i
want to say something real quick i want
to be straight forward with you guys
look yes we made the shirts hella
affordable 20 bucks t-shirt hoodies a
bit more i think 35 bucks the clothing
is nice crisp
crispy as can be and soft and yes it
might be too drippy you know school
might ban you if you wear this if you
wear this at work definitely probably
they're gonna say go get something more
professional but i want to anti-sell you
guys for a second because it's serious
put the serious music on
some of you guys are here because he got
scammed let's be honest right and so i
felt feel an obligation to say this if
you got scammed seriously actually
unironically don't don't invest in this
don't it's not an investment keep your
money if you put your roth ira into dink
doink and now you're homeless save it
save your money i don't need it you need
it right now you need to invest in
yourself and i don't mean a dan lok
course take yourself on a date maybe
half-price books maybe get some anxious
wisdom in you you know that you don't
need this shirt between me and you don't
tell anybody else you don't need it okay
now the rest of you now that got that
out of the way the rest of you who can't
afford it you do need it you do yes
no i'm serious looking to my
you need this look guys we're calling it
the crypto collection and unlike the
blockchain this won't last forever which
sounded cooler as a slogan in my head
but now it just kind of sounds like
we're it's lasting till december 31st
and then we're not selling it again
because i want to make this like a
little slice of history from coffeezilla
and then in season two or three or
whatever season we're on you can get
more the different stuff this represents
different things so again to recap this
is only for people who can afford to
support the channel and want to support
it guys and you got to love the merch so
the reason i'm stressing that is because
this merch money is not for me to live
on guys i'm fine i'm in the 10 million
studio i can eat some bushes baked beans
baby uh i actually think i have more
money than steve will do it right now
now that he quit rubet so i'm fine i
want to say this merch be super
transparent it's all about reinvestment
back into the
the channel guys you guys don't notice
we care a lot
too much frankly about production
youtube does not reward it the way they
maybe should but we care about it
nonetheless and we're going to keep
pushing forward
the levels
we want to take it to the next level
just like last year we took it from a
bedroom to the 10 million studio this
year where could we go 100 million
dollar studio who knows it could be we
don't even know that's that's the whole
point you know it could be we could get
to cyberpunk levels okay actually maybe
that wasn't such a good example uh but
the point is we're getting to hollywood
levels on a youtube budget baby and i
thought it was impossible but then oh i
was in the shower the other day and i
had an epiphany how does disney make its
movies best animation in the game not
from the box office baby they actually
make it from selling merch and basically
i want to do the same thing on a much
much much much smaller scale without all
the corporate takeover and stepping on
small artists and screwing up copyright
and you know what that's actually
another bad example and i'm on a
bad streak here but the point is i want
to get us to a place where no one can
put together the investigations and
stories we can and to support that i'm
selling some merch so you guys can come
get it if you want it i think you guys
are gonna love it i partnered with
actually a fan of the show who's an
incredible graphic designer ronan he
created the collection with my input and
i'm just excited to show it to you so
look if you like the show you like what
we've done here go take a take a poke
around our website shop coffeezilla.com
go see what you like you know maybe
don't buy anything maybe though you like
something maybe you get it for your
girlfriend maybe she doesn't know who i
am maybe she hates it because you picked
the one with my face on it i don't know
maybe she says this reflects poorly on
your judgment maybe you break up but
maybe you should have broken up a long
time ago because you needed the change i
don't know the point is when you buy
coffeezilla merch
anything can happen that's all i'm
all saying kids you said you'd save but
what a shame what a shame you're a fraud
are you the same as so you're saying no
you're not